The people that know me in Bangkok know this story. Uh, and it's
been pretty crazy. I told my actual gangstalking story today.
He actually saw this happen with me at Starbucks, uh, at Mquarter.
Uh, it was like, you couldn't even believe this. It's like out
of a movie. So, um, this has been happening the last 3 days,
and I swear to you, and nobody's going to believe me on this,
but this is for real. So, uh, there was a woman, she looked like
Hillary Clinton. She had this like black and brown, uh, black
and white hair, like Kella Deville meets Hillary Clinton. Super
woke looking woman. and she's coming to sit next to me at Starbucks.
She's like, "Oh, let me listen in on your conversation." I'm
like, "No, Antifa member. I'm not gonna let you." >> Wait,
based on her having a streak in her hair, he just said no Antifa
member.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, what? Now, how in the world you could hold Hassan
responsible
under the law for using this collar on his on his dog, I don't
I don't know. But I do believe legal mindset in in his own tradition
will probably
make that
it's it's very funny. I I assume at some point this all starts
to fall apart. Like he must be him he's building his channel
like a Jenga tower, right? And every time he you know kind of
stretches the law to be more popular, I assume he's like taking
a block out from the foundation and placing it back on top. It
has to fall at some point, right?
It has to. I pray it. But who knows, you know? Who knows?
Legal mindset is gangstalked by woke white grandmas. Okay. Well,
listen, no spoilers. Okay. I know that he's going to talk about
some like that in here. I don't know how I don't know where in
the world that comes from. So, I I saw some people talking about
how funny this video is. Okay. So, let's let's get into it. Let's
check it out. The legal mindset video.
Today we're going to talk about placing a shot collar on Hassan
as a form of punishment in the US. We're going to talk about
shot collars in the US. This is a crazy topic. It's a topic that
may get me in massive trouble. And actually uh I have been uh
away the last couple days because uh I believe it may actually
have already started some trouble for me based on my recent tweets
that I've been putting out on the shot collar incident. I've
been very very
>> vocal about this on my social media about placing a
shot collar on Hassan that I think this is an appropriate punishment
for him and I think as a result Antifa is already looking into
me and sending their thugs sending people after me. So we'll
talk about that today on this >> No way. He's actually
being gangstered for saying Hassan should wear a shot
Is that that seems like an obvious joke. the shot caller position.
Is he
is he perhaps joking about Antifa gangstalking him? We'll see.
>> It's a crazy topic. Uh it's something I'm going to get
a little bit emotional and personal about. Uh but mostly because
the last couple days have been really difficult for me. Uh being
by myself out here and dealing with some crazy stuff, possible
Antifa stalkers, woke white women stalkers. Uh this is something
we're going to get into with collaring Hassan. Of course, I've
got a >> woke white women stalkers. Okay, >> for
new viewers, that means a PowerPoint. Nothing bad, nothing dirty
means a PowerPoint. Uh, so we're going to talk about that today
uh on the legal mindset. Uh, once again, this is a fast fact
video. This is the quick and dirty version. Wait,
which came out first? Is this today? Oh, this is today. Okay,
so hold on. This is before the video. All right. Sorry. I've
been away from streaming for a few days. Been feeling under the
weather IRL, but my next topic is going to be super controversial.
So controversial it could get me killed if I present it wrong.
So, I'm putting a lot of thought into it that he can't possibly
be talking about this video.
There's there's no way that he's talking about this video about
Kaia [__] being so controversial that it could get
him, right? That would be
that would be kind of nuts. I I pray I pray it's just a different
video. Okay, he must mean after this video
he started I understand he started the video saying he didn't
stream because he was scared and now he's saying he was just
sick or sorry before it he was saying he was just sick but I'm
I'm more concerned about this whole I could get kicked for my
next video if I present it wrong. There's no way he's he's going
to try to make it seem like his opinions on Hassan's treatment
of Hassan's dog could get him killed.
Oh, I understand it's not Kai. He's afraid of black ice. I do
understand.
I'm just saying I'm detecting a hint of uh of theatrics here.
A hint of, you know, being a dramatic a dramatic uh a drama queen.
Okay, he's being a drama. >> Legal news. I'll have a live
where we go more in depth. I'm going to play the video the video
of Hassan shocking Kaya. Uh, and also some new, >> bro.
If that's not the most telling thing about all of this, he gets
the name wrong. Guys, I put a lot of thought into this video.
Okay, I put a lot of thought into this video. And just so you
know, I could get for it. So anyway, Kaya [__] Ka
[__] you know, guys, don't you know about Ka [__]
Uh, he's he's clearly he's he's fine. He's doing terrific. Okay,
video that uh Techone threw out about that. Shout out to Techone.
He's a real homie. Um, so we'll go over that on the live, but
this is the quick and dirty version where we just get through
the basics. So, let's talk about uh first of all, Antifa uh why
this is a dangerous topic. So, and this is something once again
uh it is super dangerous. I have been nervous to talk about this.
Really nervous to talk about this because
>> a lot of people are going to be pissed off with me.
Like really off and perhaps enough to kill me.
Does Antifa operate in whatever, you know,
the country he currently operates in? Like, is he in Thailand
right now?
Is he in Thailand? Is that where anti is does Antifa have a stronghold
in Thailand where they they send his shooters out? He's in Bangkok.
Oh, yeah. So, he is in Thailand. Okay. Uh,
interesting. Because this is something that is really controversial
that a lot of people out there, especially in the US, especially
right now post Charlie Kirk cuz remember we live in a post Charlie
Kirk era where people are being assa assassinated and that's
probably going to get me demonetized. People are being assassinated
in the US. Uh people are coming to up churches are coming to
Christians are coming to >> Oh, he thinks he's like Charlie
Kirk. Oh, he thinks he's like uh St. Charlie.
I don't know about that one, buddy. I don't know if you're operating
on the same plane as as Mr. Mr. Kirk was. That's that's pretty
presumptuous, dude. >> Moderates and nobody is more moderate
and based and stuck in the law and the facts and truth and justice
than me. But I will not be silenced, right? I am going to speak
up on truth and justice and freedom the way it is. I don't care
if people threaten me in my dude. Oh my god. I He's He's just
following the Teeone path where he's like the most persecuted
for saying the popular populist thing. I'm gonna Guys, nothing.
Okay, no amount of persecution will prevent me from saying the
most popular opinion on the internet. Hassan [__]
shocked his dog and deserves to have his dog taken away. Nothing,
no amount of threats will stop me from saying the thing that
everybody else is saying, that every other major influencer is
saying. Nothing will stop me. I will say it at all costs. my
life. I will give my life for freedom and truth and the law.
That's what I stand for. That's what I've always stood for. And
I'm not afraid. I'm not afraid to die for that. If I become the
Charlie Kirk in Thailand, you know, for the >> Oh, he literally
said it. He He literally
literally just
did like how do you get this kind of
My god.
Uh dangerous topic. This is controversial as people will accuse
me of racism, bigotry, cruelty towards prisoners, etc. Kanye
West's Candace Owens types will be very mad.
What?
Han orbiters, CCP and Antifa will be the most mad.
Bro, did he think a lot about this?
They're actively hunting people down in the US. You're not in
the US and I don't think they're actively hunting people down.
Oh, this is Sorry. Charlie Kirk got shot by somebody who was
possibly not even Antifa. We I I don't think we actually really
know the true political leanings of Tyler Robinson just yet.
So interesting. Just recently, Antifa was so bold as to confront
DHS in America. I'm not in America and I'm not
Okay, that probably makes you more safe. >> The fact that
I talked about, you know, a shot collar as a punishment, that's
fine. I'm willing to take that. Uh, and that that could happen
and you know that's fine. I'm okay with that. I've kind of come
to peace with that. Or because I'm a Christian, right? I'm because
I'm a Christian. That would be okay. Uh, I'm okay with that.
I have uh faith in in God, you know, which is something I haven't
talked about.
>> Oh my god. >> Donated Ruben donation. Then we
have to >> More likely to be the David Keredine of
>> I could see it. He seems like the kind of guy who knows
something about wearing like a Listen, I've watched some uh I've
watched some serial killer documentaries. All right, Legal Mindset
does seem like the kind of guy who'd put like a woman's mask
on, tie a belt around his neck, and go to town on himself hanging
off of a door. Okay, he does seem the type. He really does.
Yes, BB Poison. this idea that he is doing something one I don't
even I don't even know that I'd hate the the victim stuff if
he had some reason any reason whatsoever to present himself as
a victim. He just does the he's saying the most popular things
he can that the most people agree with and he is he's not even
saying anything controversial. He's not like making a statement.
If somebody was, you know, standing up for a principle, making
a statement, I would get it. But he's like basically saying,
"Yeah, I'm on the internet. I'm not even in America." and me
standing up and saying that like I don't know I'm a
Like he's
he's about to do the whole oh I'm going to perform the Christian
function. Okay look look guys I'm Christian. He's about to do
that and present that as another reason he might be victimized.
Brother, you don't talk about Christianity. You don't talk about
your faith. You are a total degenerate in every possible way.
You're a complete degenerate.
Oh, you
dude. There's no way.
This is like everybody everybody is following this like tape
pipeline of like, oh, I'm going to present myself as like devoutly
religious now to do away with all of my like weird degenerate
gooner past. No, that's not how that works, bro. That is not
how that works at all.
Okay, we need to go back cuz he was about to go down a whole
different a whole different rationale for being a >> with
that. Or because I'm a Christian, right? I'm because I'm a Christian.
That would be okay. Uh I'm okay with that. I have uh faith in
in God, you know. Um which is something I haven't talked about
on the channel, but you know, I'm going to throw that out there.
Once again, I'm not the perfect Christian. I'm not a perfect
person. I've made a lot of mistakes. I am very non-traditional.
Um you know, and I don't line up with all the beliefs of the
church necessarily. Um you know, and it just that's kind of something
that's >> Brother, I just I don't What are you
Why? Why would this be relevant to anything right now except
to signal out to like conservatives, hey, come watch my channel
where I talk about Hassan. Look, I'm Christian even though I
don't talk about it at all. Even though I don't follow any of
those beliefs, even though I'm not at all committed to in any
way to living out those values in the world, I I consider myself
Christian, guys. >> It's naturally coming out as part of
this conversation. Um but um uh people are going to call me racist.
They're going to call me bigoted. They're going to call me cruel
towards prisoners. That is absolutely opposite of the case. I
love everybody. I'm super cool with everybody. I've traveled
the world. I'm cool with everybody from every country. I love
traveling. I love going around the world. I love meeting new
people. I love just having random conversations with people about
stuff. That's just who I am. That's just the type of person that
I am. Uh but I'm going to stick up for truth and justice. And
when people need to be punished, I am going to punish them. Uh
or or not myself, right? But I'm going to help through the law
find a way to punish people. That's my gift. My gift is the law
speech, right? That's my superpower, if you will.
>> Uh his superpower that he up almost every single time
he talks about it, that he just doesn't know basic things. I
would legitimately trust any LLM over legal mindset. Like I would
run my I would rather run my own case than trust it to legal
mindset. Now, I wouldn't say that for any normal lawyer, right?
Just legal mindset alone.
I would rather an LLM. Whatever LLM I could get access to. Okay.
At this point, chat GPT5, anything like that. I think it's going
to do a way better job. All right. Right. So, um, that's the
thing I'm going to focus on here is the law. Now, you're going
to get in your feelings. A lot of people, Antifa, other people
watching this are going to hate watch this and they're going
to get in their feelings. They're going to be mad about this,
but listen to the end because it actually is way more humane
and way more thoughtful than people are going to think about
with the memes and the shorts and the reals. Maybe you're going
to watch a real of this or a Tik Tok of this. By the way, f I'm
going to have a new Tik Tok up. I got my Instagram rolling. So,
make sure you're following my Instagram and my Tik Tok because
those are going to get popping uh pretty soon. I got an awesome
team here. They're actually local to Bangkok. They're really
cool people. Uh shout out to Queen and uh her people and Shay.
Uh they're doing great job on my uh stuff here uh and doing that.
Um so really good uh content there. >> People are going
to still hate people. Um so the Kanye West of the world, the
Cowins are going to be >> again I just I have a hard time
describing like how
>> how stupid this is. Like and we already knew this guy
was a grifter based on how he operates his channel, right? That
he just he basically will say that this person could be punished
on the law if they're on the more popular side of any internet
beef at all, right? that's what he'll immediately do.
Um, so we already knew he's a grifter, but like to start throwing
on these different aesthetics to try to broaden your appeal to
different audiences,
I just find it really gross. He's he's also not even original
with it. He's like kind of just copying what Tech does like a
month after the fact.
Like, it's not even remotely original. It's like he watched some
month old TeeOne video about converting to Christianity and he's
like, "Oh, I should do that, too. Oh, I bet there's views in
that. I bet I bet Teto made that decision based on some analytics."
super super mad because they're gonna say it's racist, blah blah
blah. Once again, I would ask them to look at the actual prison
statistics in the US, right? And before they open their mouth
or talk and also listen to the full argument, but the most mad,
the people who are really going to be pissed off about this,
and this is the people that I believe may be stalking me because
I've already caught stalkers here before, I believe. Hold on
a second. Getting a a link to a tweet here. One second. So, this
is an example of maybe the uh the Christian the whole Christian
thing with legal mindset. Maybe this is his uh talking about
his Christianity. This was October 15th. This is earlier today,
right before we released this video. Okay. Okay. I give a lot
of love to Tifa and her big on tonight's stream. But Yuthi is
super hot, too, and has small. So, my revised Halloween proposal
is all big boob girls should play Tifa and small boob girls should
cosplay Yuthi.
The short hair and Japanese influence is A+ hot. Base legal mindset
out. Zero apologies.
Wow.
Wow, guys. He's so like Christian and like trad, right? Oh my
god. He's so conservative. He might be for his Christian beliefs,
guys. Just like Charlie Kirk. He's just like Charlie. I think
Charlie Kirk shared this opinion,
right? I think wasn't this what Charlie Kirk was talking about
with when they shot him? He was he was extolling the virtues
of anime.
Isn't that Isn't that what he was doing? Defending your right
to have a a weeb wife. Okay. A weeb waifu. I not a wee waifu.
a waifu. Okay. Possibly a very youngl looking waifu.
>> I It's just
it's upsetting. >> Johnny's crews. Uh they were stalking
me over at Bonpo, I believe. Like the just kick streamers watching
me. Um but these people, the Hassan Orbiters, the CCP, because
we all know Hassan's supported by the CCP. I mean, that laboo
love doesn't come from nowhere, right? He >> Hassan is
supported by the CCP.
So the Chinese Communist Party
supports Hassan for one thing, which by the way, Hassan loves
the the CCP. So like maybe wouldn't even be the most shocking
thing. I just have seen no evidence of it, okay? And maybe the
CCP will be mad enough, okay, that they try to do an OP on legal
mindset.
Apparently, >> the golden boy of Twitch is protected for
a reason, right? there's a reason why he's protected uh and why
he stays in LA, you know, commie central. Uh and Antifa is going
to be super bad about this. And I have been super anti- Antifa.
In fact, I've been the most actively anti- Antifa. I'm going
to show you the Carfax on that. Um and they're actively hunting
people down in the US right now. There was a confrontation between
DHS and Antifa today where I mean DHS almost got really taken
out. Um, and they're so bold as to confront >> Oh, did
this happen today? DHS almost got taken out. I want to see it.
Someone find me the video. Okay. I did I did not keep up on the
riot stuff, but apparently DHS already almost got taken out today
by Antifa. Antifa shooters were out there. They're ready to take
them down. DHS in America. So, think about that. This is not
abroad. So, I'm in Thailand. So, not everybody knows this. Some
people get confused about where I'm at, whatever. I'm in Thailand,
right? I'm in Bangkok, right? which is big to today's story and
and my sort of craziness the last couple days. But uh they're
so bold. Antifa is so important in America right now that they're
confronting DHS openly. They're just like openly coming for DHS,
openly coming for them. Just bold, right? Uh DHS needs that Pokemon
support. Okay, I'm I'm still I'm still bad at Pokemon. All right,
I'm I'm watching you guys Pokemon. Uh but anyways, guys, I'm
not in America and I'm not with DHS. I'm not DHS. I'm not as
powerful as DHS. I'm a single guy out here with a microphone
and a camera. That's who I am, right? That's all I am. And
it that's why it's so dangerous for me. And Antifa hates me.
So, here's the carf facts on this. Uh I was the one who pushed
this. I was one of the first people to >> One proper method
is to designate Antifa or at a minimum the foreign elements as
a foreign terrorist organization.
This isn't what happened, right? And Antifa was named a domestic
terrorist organization which doesn't really carry any real official
changes with it. I think it allows for greater spying on them
by domestic um like domestic law enforcement, but they weren't
named a foreign terrorist organization as far as I know. Now,
I thought they might do that as well because obviously if you're
a foreign terrorist organization, then you know, if Marco Rubio
decides he wants to do that, if you show if you show sympathies
to a foreign terrorist organization, they've kind of started
looking to take away green cards for that. So, >> push
this freaking Pam Bondi who can't get anything done. Uh, and
Andy No, who is a friend of mine, I I have him added on, uh,
of course on X. You should follow me on X as well, Andy No. Great
guy. Uh, he was the one who brought this question up to Trump.
Um, you know, Andy No. And, um, when he when he brought that
up, you know, I like to think that maybe he he considered some
of my tweets there, whatever. But I put up this PowerPoint, which
is my style. I've been doing this for a while to make it easy
for everybody to comprehend. Uh, and I said right here and September
18, 2025,
um, that one proper method is to designate Antifa or at a minimum
the foreign elements. Once again, that's why I think I'm in danger,
right, personally, because of the foreign elements of Antifa
as an FTO. >> Oh, he's he's actually laying this out as
a real argument that he's attempting to make. the the Antifa
detachment in Thailand, the Bangkok
Transifa establishment will come for legal mindset's head. Okay,
if you if you thought Transfa wasn't real, maybe they haven't
gotten a hold yet in the United States, but in Bangkok, that's
their city. Okay, Transifer run Bangkok now. All right,
and Legal Mindset knows he's put himself at real risk. >> This
can be done for allied groups which carry extreme violent beliefs
and simple and meet the simple FTO criteria. So I said, "Hey,
look, um, you know, there's an established method to do this
to the Department of State. They should do this. Pam Bondi is
not doing it because she's lazy as hell, right? And she's mainly
a political operator. She's not really good at at mass prosecution,
which is what they need in America. They need to be mass prosecuting
Antifa. It's a big risk. That's the problem right now. That's
why these confrontations with DHS are happening because
uh they're not being prosecuted. They need to be prosecuted at
a federal level. A federal level crime, which >> Okay,
hold on. federal level crime.
What federal level crime does he want them prosecuted for? Just
the members, >> which is key today because the states,
especially the woke states like California, are going to try
to stop this, right? And this all recurs within the department
of state. The department state handles this all. It's unlikely
to be blocked by judicial >> legal mindset had plenty of
interaction with Transifa Lauo. Uh based on his comments in the
past, yes, I believe he was, you know, we might find out if there
are ever, you know, there ever Antifa files similar to the Epstein
files released. We might find out legal mindset might have been
a white hatch chaser, okay? He might have been pretending to
be all into lady boys. He might have been sucking that lady boy
just for the sake of infiltrating Transifa in Thai in Thailand,
okay? and making a big difference being the number
the number one CIA asset in in Thailand. Okay.
Just like Trump, white hatch
All right. He Wait, Dan was standing. This guy. Yes. Lots of
people like this guy because he will give the most popular legal
opinion at any given time. Okay. Whatever you think should happen,
whenever you have an intuition like, "Oh, I think this should
somebody should face legal penalties for this." Legal Mindset's
there with a video to tell you you're right, even if you aren't.
>> Okay, we have to continue on here. >> Uh, it must
be challenged within 30 days. There's a limited scope of review.
It's very, very easy to get this thing passed. And there's no
uh it's never been overturned really. The FTO designation has
never been overturned. So, just declare all of Antifa and all
the foreign elements, everything linked. Just declare all that
stuff uh as an FTO. start rounding. >> Uh, yeah, I already
said that, Maximus, that when you declare somebody a domestic
terrorist organization, there's nothing to do anything with them.
It's all under the foreign terrorist organization designation.
And when you when you declare them domestic, it's like you basically
get some increased rights to spy on them likely. Uh, otherwise,
the designation probably doesn't exist. It's just like there's
not a lot of stuff on the books about what it means to be a domestic
terrorist organization. These people up, start throwing them
in jail, start punishing them, throw shot collars on them. Yeah,
we're going to talk about shot collars because Hassan and his
Antifa homies should all be wearing shot collars and doing work.
They should all be paying back for what they did. They need to
have payback. And once again, I'm not a I'm a very non-violent
person. I don't like violence, right? Uh that's why I actually
like the shot callers because they're not violent. They don't
involve killing somebody. And and once again, I I think we should
be humane to prisoners. I think that we should uh you know, be
just to prisoners. I think there's a lot of problems in prisons
like prison rape and and assault and everything else and that's
not that's not good. It's not good. It's not fair for prisoners
to have to be beat up and you know raped and have other stuff
happen to them in prison. That's messed up. Nobody should have
to go through by the way. So he's he's arguing that they should
designate the foreign elements of of Antifa
a
foreign terrorist organization. Okay. And now he's talking about
how oh we should be humane to prisoners. I assume the whole thing
he's been like bearing the lead on is he clearly is going to
argue that you should put Antifa in like shock collars or something
as a meme.
Um yeah, maybe this whole video is just satire. Okay. But honestly,
it's really not that far out there from anything he's actually
argued. So if it's satire, it's not very convincing satire. It's
like pretty clearly closely aligned with things he really believes
>> through that. Nobody should have to go through that
just because they committed a crime. Nobody should have to be
uh you know, beat up and assaulted. I really empathize for the
prisoners that have been in prison and gone through that because
that's some dark stuff that they had to go through. And man,
uh, you know, I I feel for them. I feel for them. And one way
to stop that is with the shot collars, right? Let's stop that.
Let's go through a humane way. Uh, and we can do stuff like putting
them to work. Let's, you know, let's say Antifa burns down a
city. Let's put them to work building the city back up, right?
We can do that legally in America. that's actually legal under
the Constitution because uh slavery is still legal. That's the
That's the controversial statement. I I wanted to put that in
the title, but YouTube might have uh might ding me in the title,
so I'm just going to say it. Slavery is still legal, and we're
going to talk about that today. But >> yeah, for prisoners,
obviously. >> First, let me talk about my crazy Bangkok
story, right? So, let me talk about some woke white women stalkers.
Now, some of you may not believe this, but uh the people that
know me in Bangkok know this story. Uh and it's been pretty crazy.
I told my had an actual gangstalking story today.
>> He actually saw this happen with me at Starbucks uh
at Mquarter. Uh it was like you couldn't even believe this. It's
like out of a movie. So um this has been happening the last 3
days and I swear to you and nobody's going to believe me on this,
but this is for real. So uh there was a woman, she looked like
Hillary Clinton. She had this like black and brown uh black and
white hair like Kella Deville meets Hillary Clinton. Super woke
looking woman. And she's coming to sit next to me at Starbucks.
She's like, "Oh, let me listen in on your conversation." I'm
like, "No Antifa member. I'm not going to let you." >> Wait.
Based on her having a streak in her hair, he just said, "No Antifa
>> Wait, what?
Wait, wait, what?
Hold on.
>> Woman, she looked like Hillary Clinton. She had this
like black and brown uh black and white hair like Kella Deville
meets Hillary Clinton. Super woke looking woman. And she's coming
to sit next to me at Starbucks. She's like, "Oh, let me listen
in on your conversation." I'm like, "No, Antifa member. I'm not
going to let you eaves drop on my conversation about Hassan and
about the shock collars, about everything else." No, you can't
do that. Right.
So,
I I really hope he's got something else here where he's not just
where he's not just describing his own hallucinations to a live
stream. There is no way, right? There's no way he's just like,
"Oh, I saw a woman. Uh, she had black and white hair. I knew
she was an Antifa gangstalker. Okay. I knew she was a woke old
woman trying to spy on my Hassan content. >> And there's
been these other uh woke looking women. And you can always tell
they're woke because they're ugly, right? They're ugly, right?
I uh I do not like ugly women. And Bangkok is usually full of
really hotties. It's full of really uh beautiful girls, beautiful
women, right? >> So,
every ugly old woman is Antifa by definition. And they are stalking
me by attempting to have a conversation with me. Wow.
Incredible stuff from Andrew here. The the the
criminal coalition
against Hassan. They're they're getting the best. All right.
Naku, Legal Mindset, Techone. These guys are some of the best
online. They're some of the best operating. All
They're not totally just
They're not totally just the most
lowife,
unprincipled pieces of [__] that exist on planet
Earth. That's not what's going on. They're totally principled.
They're totally like making good points out here, okay? They're
definitely people you should rely on for
Lady Lady Boy Mindset on the run and you can't keep these evil,
horny liberal women off of him. Ugly old horny liberal women.
Okay. BB Poison
and he knows that they're just trying to get his content. They're
trying to figure out how to how to undo his content, how to prevent
him from posting it because they are all a part of Antifa. >> Right?
I know what you're thinking. Oh, they're all lady boys. No, no,
no, no. Beautiful, real women, right? They're normally everywhere.
But the last couple days, I've been seeing a lot of ugly women.
A lot of really ugly. They're frowning, right? Woke women are
never happy, right? They're always frowning. They're always unhappy.
They're scowlling at you. They're looking mean, right? They're
meanmugging you. They're like looking at you like they're gonna
kill you, right? That is uh that's the woke woman. That's the
woke woman out there. And that's been who's been looking at me.
It's been all woke women. There's been no hotties smiling at
me or something like that like normal. It's been all these crazy
woke women. And I'm like, what's going on with that? Like what's
going on Bangkok? Usually everyone's friendly or whatever. Now
everyone's grumpy. Maybe because it's raining or something. And
there's all these woke. >> So again, old
ugly and frowning automatic Antifa.
automatic. Okay. Woke women, they're always mad. They're always
upset. I
sure
this this video has to be satire. It has to be. Okay.
It has to be. But he's speaking as if he's serious. So I I don't
know. Now I'm feeling by this video. Oak women around me. And
I thought about it and I'm like, "Oh, Antifa. Oh, obviously it's
Antifa, right? Obviously they got word of this. Obviously, there's
something that they know uh that's coming cuz I've talked about
this and they're uh they're trying to put some pressure on me,
right? But I'm not going to be shut up. I will not be silenced,
Antifa. You're not going to scare me. If I die for this, I'm
willing to die for this. Like Charlie Kirk, I'm willing to go
Charlie Kirk on this one, right? Uh and I also want to Okay,
asold
has to understand how offensive this is that legal mindset's
comparing himself to Charlie Kirk, right? This is way worse than
making a joke about Charlie dying. This is so much worse. This
is a This is a lollycon
transchaser
total degenerate loser comparing himself to St. Charlie.
How are conservatives not going to lose their minds about this
This guy can't be real right now. This can't be real.
Talk about this. Being abroad isn't safer, right? We talked about
Charlie, right? Um, and after Charlie, I uh I want to give a
shout out to Danielle, my mod, who's uh autism, or rather I should
say Talenol American, that's how we say it. Her Talonol American
powers have probably saved my life uh because she told me to
start studying OPSE after the death of Charlie Kirk. And I started
studying a lot of the the CIA field manuals, looking up YouTube
videos, stuff like that just to protect myself because I'm here
alone.
guys, the way I detected these Antifa woke white women stalking
me was I started reading CIA manuals, okay? Field manuals on
how to do actual spycraft. Bro, I'm telling you, white hatch
chaser infiltrating Transifa in real time. All right. Yes, he
is. He does work for the CIA. He isn't infiltrating Antifa. He
can't say it. So, he has to he can't say that he's infiltrating
Antifa. Okay. or the CIA transa within Thailand because
it would obviously blow his cover. So he has to do this skitso
post. He has to make them think that he's losing his mind. So
they come further. So they further attempt to contact him. Okay,
he's just building his case. All right, I see it. Legal mindset.
I see what's actually going on here. I get it. And a lot of people
think living abroad is safer, but these people can just travel.
They can get on a plane and they can come. In fact, they do that
often. They come from Canada. They come from Europe to the United
States to cause problems. And Thailand's super easy to come to.
You can show up here. Anybody can show up. And a lot of people
think it's safer abroad. That is a misnomer. It's actually more
dangerous. Uh my good friend Mark recommended the the book Private
Dancer, which is an extremely intuitive book, especially not
to be a s for beautiful women. Although it's hard. My my weakness
is beautiful women, especially if they have big and like anime
and have a goth style. But that's my weakness, right? Okay. I
shouldn't expose my weaknesses.
>> Just like Charlie. just I believe Charlie also said
that that he he would go online and talk about how he loves like
weeaboo big goth girlfriends. I think that was like that was
part of Charlie's gospel. Yeah, just like >> But that's
my weakness. I was my >> I think that's a major Turning
Point platform is they want to push Trump to give goth girlfriends
to all men under 40 in the US. Right. That's a huge part of the
Turning Point USA platform. That's how they get all the young
people on board. I think >> fortunately it's cost me much
but anyways
um that's besides the point. Uh private dancer one of the best
scenes in that is at the end of the book. So this guy he gets
on a motorbike and someone just rolls up and pops him in the
head. Right? And that is very easy to do here. You can hire you
could get somebody to do that and nobody would know. Right? Antifa's
got enough money. They got Soros. They got all the money in the
world. Right? They're funding ops all over the all over the US.
They're funding ops all over the world. So for me who's got nobody
out here, so you're all alone. Yeah, that's pretty scary. It's
pretty scary when you're all alone out there somewhere. And Antifa
could be coming for you, right? And that this guy is unironically
describing gangstalking right now. Like just fully no irony,
not no satire. He's just describing how he's being gangstaled
by Antifa in Thailand with like no evidence. The evidence is
an ugly white woman tried to talk to me, tried to ask me what
I was talking about at a Starbucks in Bangkok. And that's how
I knew I was being gangsted by Antifa. Okay, guys. >> That's
why I say to you guys, if anything happens to me, you know it's
Antifa. You know it's the, you know, Hassan's homies, whatever
else. >> Is this guy trying to set himself up for like
an insanity defense? Like, did he did he do something illegal
in Thailand and he's like trying to set up an insanity defense
now? he like some white woman in an alley in Thailand and he's
basically like he's building up this like delusion that he was
being hunted down and he needs like an alibi like that that seems
like way more likely than this could actually be serious
planning to fake his own death something like this right it's
like I'm immediately going to the most skitso myself to describe
why this guy would start making this up at this moment in
>> right they're clearly the ones that got me right so
if anything happens to me >> like this is like the Andrew
Tate like started talking about the Matrix, but when he knew
that he was going to get prosecuted, right? Oh, the Matrix is
going to try to stop me. They're going to try to stop the message,
guys. Yeah, you because you It's like this. I feel like I feel
like that's what I'm seeing here is this guy did something bad
and he is going to say he got entrapped. He's going to use it
as a way to get out of whatever bad thing he was accused of
He's like building up an alibi or some plausible deniability
right now. 100%. >> Me or my family or my friends or whatever.
It's definitely >> Oh, also I got to pull this back. I
just need to walk away for two seconds. I'll be right back. >> You
get somebody to do that and nobody would know, right? Antifa's
got enough money. They got Soros. They got all the money in the
world, right? They're funding ops all over the all over the US.
They're funding ops all over the world. So for me, who's got
nobody out here? So you're all alone. Yeah, that's pretty scary.
It's pretty scary when you're all alone out there somewhere and
Antifa could be coming for you, right? And that's why I say to
you guys, if anything happens to me, you know it's Antifa. you
know, it's the, you know, Hassan's homies, whatever else, right?
They're clearly the ones that got me, right? So, if anything
happens to me or my family or my friends or whatever, it's definitely
Antifa, okay? Know that it's Antifa for sure. 100% it's Antifa,
right? So, just go and look into that and look into all the connections
there and the local connections and stuff like that and figure
out who did it, right? Take revenge for me, chat. Take revenge.
Uh but that would be uh that would be what would be happening
there obviously
100%. Just remember the evidence was an ugly old angryl looking
white woman tried to start a conversation with him at a Starbucks.
That's the evidence. That's the evidence is an one,
possibly two, but I believe it was just one,
maybe two. Angry old ugly white woman who is clearly woken a
part of Antifa because she was ugly, angry, and old attempted
to talk to him.
>> Um, okay. Very good book though, by the way. Everyone
should definitely read >> He did. He did just ask his chat
to investigate and get revenge if he's killed in Thailand.
>> Okay. Next, uh, let's talk about what the actual subject
here, which is Hassan hating dogs, not my crazy Bangkok life.
Although, I do want to start doing more IRL stuff here because
Bangkok's really cool and a lot of people need to see that. So,
I'm going to be doing some more IRL streaming over here, but
that's neither here nor there. Um, but respectful IRL, not Johnny
Somali style, right? Not Johnny Somali style. Okay. Uh, anyways,
Hassan hates dogs. Hassan hates dogs. So, uh, in case you haven't
seen this, and this is something that's been trending in the
US everywhere. It's all over social media right now. English
language social media. It's all over. It's Hassan shocking. Obviously,
this is
Oh, you know, I miss that Keles's mo. There's an actual Ke's
moment right there, guys. I fear for my life. But, um, but I'm
going to I'm going to start doing IRL streams. You know, I'm
going to start I'm having fun streaming. I'm going to do some
IRL streams. All right. I know. I know. It might be dangerous.
It might be. It might be like, you know, you could argue that
I could easily get from giving my location away in real time.
But, you know, I based on this based on this feeling of being
gangstaled, I'm going to go start live streaming my location.
But, he slapped that shop collar on him and shocked her. There's
also another video which I'll show in my live version. Watch
the live for that one. Uh, and that's him like essentially
torturing this animal. And this is absolutely cruel and really
really hurts me. And hold on, hold on, hold on. Wait, do we have
to find his live now? Where's the Where's the time stamp for
that? Him actually torturing the animal. I want to see that.
You kind of made the same argument about DG not too long ago.
What argument was
I don't I literally don't know what argument you're making.
>> Uh, go ahead, Gregor Samson. >> And I want to
talk about Moudang. I want to talk about muoudang, right? Muddang
and my love for mudang here. And now some of you have not been
to Thailand. You don't know who Muang is and you don't know what
this thing is behind me. I'm going to explain real quick. Mudang
is a pig being doxed and harassed. Uh I said somebody was trying
to dox me and calling for me to be killed and then the leader
of the group DGG literally did those things. Onetoone correspondence.
You think it's a similar argument or I think you would have to
I think you would have to be like
totally subhuman to think that and not use your brain whatsoever.
But I sure maybe maybe you could argue that. I
I'm sorry that's like totally crazy.
That's totally crazy to try to compare those two things. But
all right,
>> I just
>> I just want you to sit there and stew on that, Gregor
Samson, that you just said those words. That's very goofy, man.
>> The cow the cow zoo. It's near It's north of Patia.
Uh she is adorable. She's a little bit fatter now, but even though
she's a little fatter, I still
>> Wait, why? How is this freak Ka punished us on Fast
Facts? He just switched over to Mudang for no reason. >> Love
her. I still love her. Right. Uh, she's like my daughter and
um, this is my weakness and I got to I'll go full screen on this
one cuz we got to showing this day, right? And by the way, I
gave this mooding a hat because I like the hats. They symbolize
freedom in Thailand. Why? Why can I wear clothes? Like I don't
get it. Anyways, this is mud. I love mooding. I'm moving plushy.
Like I may or may not sleep with this. It's kind of I am a good-hearted
person and I have a weakness for good-hearted women. Probably
because I grew up in a hat. They have big with all bro. Bro,
and by the way, the west has no more good-hearted women. That's
why he had to go east. All right. >> So, my weakness is
good-hearted women. And it's much to my detriment. Once again,
if they have big dick, they like anime. Uh a big a big girl with
likes anime and has a good heart is my number one weakness and
I will fall in love with them, right? Which is which is my problem,
right? Uh but anyways, this is mudang. It's mud. Mudang symbolizes
to me purity and purity of heart because mudang, how can you
not like muang? How can you not like mud? And if anybody was
to hurt Muang, I would hunt them down and I would make them suffer,
right? If they were if they were trying to hurt Muang, I would
make them suffer. I love Muang. Mang is like my daughter, right?
Right. And I've got actually I've got a friend of mine here who's
kind of like a daughter to me. I love her. She's great. And that's
my weakness. Good-hearted women, right? Good-hearted pure-hearted
women, right? That have a pure heart and that are kind and that
are caring, right? Like that's exactly what I love, right? That's
my weakness. And I once again I know I shouldn't talk about weaknesses,
but Muang is my weakness, right? But if >> I tried skipping
through, he just keeps yapping about garbage. >> Okay,
Mudang's back in her place. Okay. So, I would >> he he
went from okay, I'm being gangstaled by Antifa because of these
like
signs that don't put to that at all to Oh, yeah. Hassan like
totally tortured his dog and you can see that on my live stream.
So, go open the live stream to Muang. Mudang's awesome. Where's
the Where are the Ka [__] facts that are coming up?
>> You got to make sure Mang. Okay. Is Moodang okay? >> We're
gonna get Ka [__] stuff, right? Okay. Yeah. >> You
got to take good care of Mudang. You gota take very good care
of Mudang. >> Eventually, we get to something like an argument
here. >> Take care of Mudang. So, uh, I just get emotional
about mud. I love mud so much. I love him so much. Anyway, I
see I'm distracted. I don't even know where it was. But anyways,
John Lef the pirate. I'm like a pirate, you know. I just like,
you know, gold and
um Matt Nelt. That's what I thought he was trying to do at first.
I thought he was trying to say that
basically he was going to make some argument about treating like
he's going to say human prisoners should wear shot collars, right?
And I assume he was going to try to do an analogy to having to
stay in this very small area from the shot collar and how inhumane
that looks when you talk about it happening to a human. Now,
obviously that would be on its face completely moronic because
a dog is not a human. A dog does not form complex thoughts in
the way a human does, right? So it' be moronic on its face. But
he hasn't even gotten to that yet. He's just gone in eight different
skits directions about nothing. >> You know, gold and freedom
and women, right? It's all good for me. It's all it's all by
my my motivations, right? Um I also think is it is it such a
sin to like those things? No. No. Right. People try to make people
try to shame me and make me feel bad for being a male. I'm sorry.
Right. I'm not going to apologize for that. Um but that said,
>> nobody has once ever tried to make you feel bad for
that ever. >> Um like with this I think about Muang and
I think about somebody torturing Muang and I would definitely
want to punish them. So let's talk about punishment. Let's talk
about this. Uh let's talk about slavery in the United States
and the legality of slavery for prisoners in the US and that's
based on the 13th amendment to the constitution. Now under that
and once again a lot of people don't know this. They haven't
studied this well enough, right? Which is not their fault. Not
every lawyer is as smart as I am. Some lawyers are kind of literally
every lawyer that's ever looked at the constitution understands
this. Literally every single one probably
every single lawyer who graduates law school graduates with this
fact in their like imbued into their mind.
It's bordering on common knowledge in average people, but for
every lawyer who's ever looked at the Constitution, they absolutely
know that that's how like for-profit prisons work is they don't
have to pay real wages. Those people are not subject to like
a minimum wage in the same way. Everybody knows this. It's not
even remotely like trivia half. And they don't know what they're
talking about. Maybe they they're just joking around. They're
like kind of joke lawyers or pretend lawyers or, you know, they're
like scam lawyers or something like that. They're like scammer
lawyers. But uh you know the 13th amendment to the constitution
says neither slavery nor involuntary servitude uh except as a
punishment for crime whereof the party shall be duly convicted
shall exist within the United States or any place subject to
their jurisdiction. So the key here is except as punishment for
crime whereof the party shall be duly convicted. So what that
means is slavery and indentured servitude is legal. Once again
controversial. This could get me in trouble. This get me kicked
for saying slavery is legal because think about the headlines.
People are going to say legal mindsets says slavery is legal.
Okay listen to the whole video idiot. Right? finish the video
and you'll know I'm talking about the Constitution, which is
what it says. And no, that's not something that I'm trying to
go off on a wild interpretation. Look up the facts. The majority
of prisoners in the US are Who is he? He's like shadow boxing
with people who just know this. Most people just know this. There's
nobody who's watching this video going, "What? You think slavery
is legal? That's insane legal." Nobody's doing that. They're
like obviously going to wait for you to make a point. Although,
they might have actually lost it at the at the Antifa part where
you're being ganged and just left the video. That's possible.
>> Are forced to do uh labor. They're forced to do labor
in prison. It's normal in prison in the US. Now, woke states
like California uh are trying to get rid of that. I'll talk about
that later. But uh and some people hate the truth. They hate
the fact that the truth in the US is that slavery is legal for
prisoners. Once again, it's important for prisoners, not regular
people, right? We're not talking regular people. We're talking
about for prisoners. Okay? And that's the truth. And if you don't
like that, you don't like the truth. Okay? And I will die speaking
for the truth of freedom. That's worth it for me. I stand for
the truth of freedom. I'm not afraid for that. Right? You know,
once again, if I dive on the >> I will die speaking for
the truth and freedom. I will die to make this
trivial point
just to go after Hassan [__] I will I will die arguing
that Hassan [__] should be put in a shot collar if
he's convicted of a crime. I will die for this truth to put this
truth out into the ether. Okay, I will die for it. Cool. So,
so cool. I will
uh this guy
Are him and Techone doing like a competing thing to see who can
lose like like how stupid their followers are? Like they're actually
just trying to compete for who has the most following. Like how
dumb can I sound in a video before people go, "Oh, wait. I need
to uh I need to pull back
before one of them goes like negative in subs." I think they
have a bet over who can get more and not lose subs. Have you
checked the comments on this video? They're hilarious. I've not
checked the comments yet. I fully believe that there are going
to be people who are like, "Andrew, take care of yourself. Take
care of yourself. I know they're coming for you. Don't let them
get you like they got Charlie. Char if I'm Charlie Kirk for standing
up for truth or freedom." I said,
"Uh, whatever. It just happened, you know, like I got, you know,
I was speaking up for truth and freedom. That's that's worth
it, right? That's worth it. Some things are worth it in life.
That's worth it for me." Uh, is truth and freedom. Always. I
will always stand for truth and freedom. So, um,
>> he will always stand for truth and freedom. Hold on.
Let's, uh, hop over to this clip real quick.
>> Right. Which
>> hold on this one. I used to have this one from >> I
can understand having been in the Philippines cuz I can say this
and this is all due respect. There's nothing about Lady Boy,
>> guys. He will die. He will die. Okay, he will die for
this opinion. >> This is all due respect. There's nothing
about Lady Boy, not Lady Boy. It's just the Philippines versus
Thailand. Thailand has a more of a sabai cool attitude. You know,
Philippines is way more aggressive. Uh especially I don't know,
man. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. The Filipino lady boys,
I can tell you this in Manila. And you're an >> I can see
how that was imported here are far more aggressive than the Thai
lady
>> until they're not until it changes, until the ties snap
and it's light. >> Yeah, but that's a >> This guy's
got a lot of experience with lady boys in both of these countries.
Yeah, true. You know, >> like off rip something. Next thing
you know, it's it's the gangs in New York on Soy 11 featuring
all the lady boys, >> I wonder if he could make like a
YouTube channel where he could explain to us how to get to these
countries with a surplus of lady boys. And
>> and I wonder if he'd even have a little more advice
on on how to get like, you know, get their numbers, get in contact
with them. It'd be crazy if you had like a YouTube channel that
where you could teach people these things, right? Hotties is
what he calls them apparently. What was I don't care if people
threaten me in my life. I will give my life for freedom and truth
and the law. That's what I stand for. That's what I've always
stood for. And I'm not afraid. I'm not afraid to die for that.
If I become >> this is going to be >> Charlie Kirk
in Thailand, you know, for the fact that I talk about, you know,
a shot collar as a punishment. That's fine. I'm willing to
Dude's probably on prep and thinks he's Charlie Kirk.
>> Take that. Uh, and that that could happen. And, you
know, that's fine. I'm okay with that. I've kind of come to peace
with that. Or because I'm a Christian, right? Because I'm a Christian.
That would be okay. Uh, I'm okay with that. This is [__]
This is maybe the most absurd video I've ever I've and I've I've
seen a lot of absurd videos from this guy. This is maybe the
most absurd video he's ever put into the ether. Okay, this is
crazy on here. There's cruel and unusual punishment under the
eth amendment. The eth amendment says excessive bail shall not
be required, nor excessive fines imposed, nor cruel and unusual
punishments inflicted. Uh, leftist states want this to prevent
forced labor completely and make jails like country clubs. They
want to make jail like it's a party or whatever, which it shouldn't
be. You should have on some level you should have to pay back
to society or you should be doing work to build up right if you
did something wrong you need to restore that right you need to
make it good and that's normal right do something wrong make
it good that's the basic principle if I did something wrong I
would make it good right and I people all know that everyone
knows that if I did something wrong and you tell me directly
not indirectly you tell me directly exactly what I did wrong
then I will make it right everybody knows that however um this
sort of thing about uh forced labor and jails that is strongly
opposed by Trump, right? Uh that should be, sorry, this should
be I said that wrong. Trying to make jails country clubs should
be opposed by Trump and should be opposed by the right. The left
is is wants to make them, you know, like Norway or whatever the
Scandinavian countries that have like they're giving people PlayStation
fives and like they're giving them like king beds and stuff.
Uh no, we don't need that. >> What we need is we need uh
real punishment and that's where shot colors come in. shot collars
would be more humane than >> so yeah, maybe this whole
thing is to set up like a like a metaphor for Kaia where you
like you're going to say, "Oh, this is wrong." And you're but
you would argue it's not wrong when they do it to Ka. This is
like what the whole thing is going to set up, right? Ka's doing
labor by sitting in place and she's shocked when she stops doing
her job of sitting in place and then you're supposed to go and
freak out when he says he wants to do it to humans and then he's
gonna go, "Well, you want it you want it on dogs?" Yes. which
is already stupid on its face because dogs do not have the the
level of consciousness, the the ability to form complex thoughts
that human humans have, right? It is not the same thing.
It's not the same thing at all >> in violence, right? So
once again, you don't have to beat up a prisoner, right? The
prison guards don't have to beat people up anymore, right? That
takes away a lot of the violence, the hate for the guards and
stuff like that. It's a shock. Yeah, it's going to hurt, but
you're not going to die, right? It will correct you, but it will
>> more humane than violence. Allow for freedom of movement.
Allow for remote triggering, safety, immediate corrective punishment,
cost effective. Do it in a non-lethal way and something that
doesn't inflict permanent damage. It's it's just temporary, right?
It allows for freedom of movement so you can move around more.
They don't have to be in cells. They can be more like comfortable
in the prison, right? They can just move around because if somebody
does anything bad, the guards in a booth with cameras or drones
or whatever can just watch them in remote trigger, right? So
you can just say, "Oh yeah, boom. This guy's, for example, let's
say prison essay, right? We have to say SA because of YouTube,
but we all know what we're talking about, right? Actually, I
said it earlier, but like prison, right? If if you see another
prisoner about the another prisoner, you just hit the button
and the buzzer and all of a sudden that stops. All of a sudden,
the violence stops. All of a sudden, that that stops. And if
you have a camera everywhere, then you can just see, oh, look,
this guy's trying to do that zap, right? And stop them from doing
that versus now where the guards got to go down there and get
involved and he might die or, you know, take his weapon or whatever
else. So, they can't stop that, right? So, this is makes it safer
for the Does Legal Mindset realize that like even if even if
this weren't just a joke where he's trying to do a gotcha, right?
Even if that weren't what this is,
even in that case, this is too expensive. Nobody's doing this
for prisoners. >> Prisoners, right? Because we're in the
shot college, right? And you can make them comfy. You can don't
have to make them like uncomfortable. Uh they can we have the
technology to do this, right? And it's immediate corrective punishment.
So it's like Pavlovian like training a dog, right? You know,
it's like, okay, don't do this, right? And then they're going
to do that, right? Um and you know, once again, this is why,
you know, if Hassan is using it to train the dog, right? Well,
okay. If Assan thinks it's okay, well then whatever, then it
needs to be used for prisoners. Once again, equality. This is
why I'm saying Hassan needs to wear the shot collar because he
needs to get the same punishment, right? It's also cost effective.
And once again, limit this to users that offenders that deserve
it. Really bad prisoners. Not every prisoner maybe deserves this,
but you know, some prisoners, I mean, we'll think about it deeply.
This is just my random thought here that I came up with, right?
It's not perfect. I'll probably have to do future episodes on
this to hone this down and answer criticisms of this. Uh, but
just off the cuff, you know, don't make it based on race, natural
origin. Apply it fairly. Apply it to everybody, you know? Um,
and so my conclusion is Assan [__] deserves to experience
the pain of a shot collar as fairness for what happened to Kayla.
Uh, the judge is >> Dude, it's such a transparent grift
when he can't get Kaya correct. When he can't even, he hasn't
done enough looking into this to hear the name be said. He has
only ever read it. He's never watched a single clip or done any
research. He is just he's saying ka ka ka. He does he's not invested
enough to get the name
as wild >> then his rights to order this. They can do this
under the current constitution. Now, it probably needs to be
a federal offense. Wake up, Pam Bondi. Wake up. Uh and so leftist
states like California don't ban it, right? So, uh cuz they're
not going to be the ones to do this. The feds have to do this.
So, Trump has to get this message. Maybe Baron Trump watches
a meme on uh Instagram or Tik Tok and and somebody passes the
me, like, "Hey, Baron Trump, check out this legal mindset video."
And uh gets a hold of this because uh I think this this was a
federal offense, something involving, you know, uh you know,
at a federal level. Uh we could do this. We do this right away.
This would be like quick. You could even take the collars that
exist and just like modify them for human size probably and that
would work. I don't know. I'm not a I'm not an engineer. I'm
a simple lawyer alone here in Bangkok. Uh but that's all I have
for today. Hopefully you've enjoyed this episode. It's been a
little bit different. Uh but a little bit uh open and honest
about some things. Uh which may or may not get me in trouble,
but who cares, right? Whatever. >> Little open and honest
about things about his insane paranoia, his insane lack of tether
to reality. Until >> next time. Peace,
This has to just destroy. Okay,
the Hassan thing was by far was almost certainly the least offensive
section there, right? The Hassan bit that was like less offensive
than everything else. He's probably wrong, but dude, that that
Antifa thing, how do you even take this guy seriously? He's just
describing to you like schizophrenia.
Like he's he's just coming on a YouTube stream without realizing
it and going, "Yeah, I'm I'm totally schizophrenic. Yeah, I'm
I'm reading CIA field manuals to keep myself safe from woke,
ugly, angry looking white women to keep them from talking to
me in public.
Yikes, man. Oh, also the whole Christian group dude.
Dude, this guy this guy is out of his mind.